If it's too hard to shower
today, grab the baby wipes.
It may not be the normal way to doit,
but you deserve to be clean.
If it's too hard to cook dinner,
get paperplates, heat up something frozen.
You’ll go back to cooking and
washing another day,
but theday is not today.
And in the meantime, you deserve to eat.
If you're too depressed to do your dishes,
get a two-gallon Ziploc bag
and keep it in your bedroom.
Because if you put a dirty plate into a
two-gallon Ziploc bag and seal it,
it will keep the bugs away.
Because you deserve a sanitaryenvironment
even if you can't get out of bed.
I could share with you hundreds
of othergenius solutions
that people have come up with
once they embraced the idea
that care tasksare morally neutral.
In my experience, people will exhibit
mind-blowing creativity
when they are onlytaught how to speak
compassionately to themselves.